funny you show me how to do I want
people feeling the hair flip - oh my
gosh there was no manipulation with Rosa
seriously thing is amazing
wait and also I want to say because we
were having a game soft before you came
because we're obsessed with hands to
myself
we were really literally being like
hands to myself I've had I'm trying to
oh this missus sexy you're not sick you
should get out they're known for I
thought you should just or in that stage
Kanye's down to see us do it you're like
no forget that
Selena we have to let's talk about the
driver looks like that I know I'm dying
I'm wearing Calvin Klein and I'm very
happy because I wanted to feel like a
blue sapphire rocks
I believe all I don't even know what I
wanted to feel like I just loved it
now a lot of your fitness it good night
for I feel like your whole Frank or
Justin Bieber one tonight to its first
ever Grammy was very happy that my no
honestly so cool I like I like skrillex
and diplo through their often they have
such a cool energy amongst all of them
to be able to create something like that
- really great